blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
davidpackman I'm starting today with
something that is the perfect Nexus of
ignorance and nationalism I think is the
way I would put it uh the unhinged
nationalism in fact of some of the new
trumpian members of Congress really
knows no bounds and it even now is being
applied to American territories whose
residents are citizens of the United
States and I'm talking about none other
than radical outrageous disgusting
depraved and delusional congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green of course of
Jewish space laser Fame she said at a
side panel a sort of breakout session at
CPAC a couple of weeks ago that American
taxpayer money shouldn't go to foreign
countries like wait for it Guam now Guam
is of course an American territory the
people of Guam are American citizens the
reason it took us a couple of weeks to
hear about this even though CPAC was a
couple of weeks ago is that it was at
one of these breakout sessions so what
we watched on TV from CPAC that wasn't
all they also had breakout sessions with
smaller groups where a lot of the things
said were even nuttier and even more
ignorant if you can imagine that it was
filmed here is Marjorie Taylor green
saying no more money for foreign
countries like uh Guam where everybody's
an American citizen and I wanted to take
my regular person normal everyday
American values which is we love our
country
we believe our hard-earned tax dollars
should just go for America
not for what China Russia the Middle
East Guam whatever wherever
right if we want to build roads if we
want to put money into schools if we
want to build border walls we want it
right here at home no more money
for foreign countries like Guam this
reminded me of course and I think it
reminded many many others of the whole
Puerto Ricans should go back to their
country Puerto Ricans of course are
American there is no country to go back
to it's part of the United States and on
a serious note this really does
reinforce the importance of normalizing
the status of places like Puerto Rico
and Guam and others green as an elected
official should know what is part of the
United States and what is not
but this is also another reminder as if
we needed one that the way we deal with
Puerto Rico and Guam and others like
American Samoa it really makes no sense
in many ways we do treat them as if they
are foreign countries there are
different statuses for different
territories people born on American
Samoa for example are U.S Nationals but
they're not U.S citizens people from
Puerto Rico and Guam are U.S citizens at
Birth it's a mess and it needs to be
fixed but what foreign country does she
think Guam is anyway
now Marjorie Taylor green is a [ __ ]
that yes she has no business being in
the House of Representatives and this
proves that there needs to be serious
consideration given to the status of
overseas territories she's in Congress
she should know without a doubt but the
truth is if you ask your average person
in the street
is Guam uh its own country or a U.S
territory many people would have no idea
this isn't completely unique to the
United States I think if you go to the
UK and you ask people about some of the
more obscure British territories I think
many people in the UK also wouldn't know
but the issue is people in government
should know and these territories as far
as the U.S is concerned do not have
adequate representation in their own
government so it's particularly it's a
it's a a vicious cycle when they don't
have adequate representation and then
our elected officials sometimes don't
even know that they are lacking the
representation because they don't even
know that it's part of the United States
unless it's convenient for some other
reason like for example
when Republicans want to talk about how
bad a job a Democratic president is
doing on controlling North Korea they
will say North Korea could hit U.S
territories with missiles like Guam then
it's convenient then all of a sudden
they figure out Guam is a U.S territory
there are many Americans who don't
realize Puerto Rico is part of the U.S
Puerto Ricans are U.S citizens there are
some Americans who think New Mexico is
part of Mexico rather than a U.S state
there's plenty of ignorance to go around
but Marjorie Taylor green is an elected
official and it's very politically
relevant so just another confirmation
that she has no business no business
whatsoever serving in government and
hopefully she will either not run for
re-election in 2022
or be voted out in a bloodbath election
let's hope for the latter I think it
would be more more entertaining
Evangelical televangelist grifter
Christian Pat Robertson turns 91 in just
a few days he is still going with his
700 Club show
the show has been on the air for so long
that the list of things that Pat has
said are demonic is now really long as a
reminder over the years the following
can be or are demonic according to Pat
Robertson second-hand sweaters from a
thrift shop
Ouija boards yoga Harry Potter feng shui
karate horoscopes the Twilight series
paintings of Buddha TV shows about
ghosts Halloween psychics girls who
levitate their friends at sleepovers and
sometimes even adopted children from
other countries can be demonically
possessed according to Pat Robertson we
now are adding something new to the list
even little babies just out of the womb
completely vulnerable to the world's
dangers can be demonically possessed
check this out Pat Robertson answering a
question from a caller named Lisa as
always with this show I don't know if
the caller is a serious or participating
in some kind of satire it appears to be
real and Pat Robertson certainly takes
it seriously all right here's the caller
Lisa from Fallen Nevada
my question is regarding demon
possession 10 babies be possessed and if
so does the age of accountability come
into play for salvation
um
can babies be possessed and if so does
the age of accountability come into play
for salvation well the age of
accountability has to do at the point
you know what we're right from wrong and
that normally doesn't take a place that
you're old enough to understand
something's wrong so the age of
accountability can be five it can be six
it can be four it could be three but can
a baby be demon possessed I just believe
if if
that child is born to a family of devil
worshipers there's a real possibility
that the the the the devil will think
that he has a claim over that child I
mean it's horrible to contemplate but I
don't think that they're protected in
some fashion from uh what's it I mean a
generational curse but normally a little
baby as I say there's no such thing as a
as a sinful baby it was a baby that
never know he or she's doing anything
wrong so they're free from the law but
not necessarily free from the influence
of Satan all right it could be a
generational curse or simply being born
to devil worshipers and yes a baby can
be demonically possessed remember that
if there are soon to be parents in the
audience now importantly it wouldn't be
because the babies have sinned I guess
that's is that nice I don't know if
that's better or worse the babies that
are demonically possessed would only be
demonically possessed either because
um of uh some kind of transgenerational
uh possession
um or because of something that that the
parents did or believed maybe that's
reassuring in some way you can't come
out of the womb immediately a sinner and
if you think that this is entirely
nonsense there are stories of parents
who have killed their kids because they
become convinced the kids are possessed
by the devil it just happened a few
months ago December 21st article from
krcg TV a a Benton County couple in
Missouri in custody for torturing and
beating uh the family a four-year-old
died and the couple said they were
torturing the family because the mother
was possessed by a demon
another one from October of 2019 a man
drowned his six-year-old son while
trying to cast out a demon I could go on
there are many many more of these it's
not merely grifting it is a type of
nonsense that has real world impact
admittedly the impact seems to be
primarily on those who are already
probably quite mentally ill and lacking
Mental Health Services but it's giving
them ideas if nothing else and Pat
Robertson's still going I don't know how
long this show is going to go on it's
been on the air for a very long time by
the way for people who don't know the
story of the 700 Club I'm going from
memory I believe the reason it's called
the 700 Club is that early on Pat found
I don't know if it's actually 700 or
roughly 700 of his friends or people
willing to give him money to start this
show it's extraordinarily lucrative and
it has been on air for decades I don't
know if it still airs on ABC Family I
can't imagine a show less family
friendly than this to be to be totally
honest with you but an incredibly
successful Institution the 700 Club with
Pat Robertson and Pat as I mentioned
just about 10 days of March 22nd
March 22nd Pat Robertson's birthday
um so that's what's going on there
babies uh you know I have a lot of
friends who are new parents babies could
be demonically possessed on Friday March
26th we are doing a one day membership
blowout why are we doing this I've been
honest about why the pandemic is getting
a lot of people down economically in
February we had the most cancellations
of memberships of any month ever on the
David Pacman show being a 28-day month
we also had fewer new subscriptions we
had a significant net loss of
subscribers in February so we're trying
to do something to Kickstart 2021 on
Friday March 26th we will be doing a
one-day membership special it'll be a
huge discount I believe the coupon code
will be uh a covid-19 theme and it'll be
it'll be good because of growing
vaccinations and decreasing cases and
all of that stuff I would love for you
to get access to this special all you
have to do is get on my newsletter at
joinpakman.com I'm sorry at
davidpackman.com go to davidpackman.com
sign up for the newsletter Friday
morning March 26th you will get a
perfect email from me telling you
exactly how to take advantage of this in
the meantime have you dealt with demonic
possession let me know I'm on Twitter at
dpacman the David Pacman show at
davidpackman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist then what they do is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich Yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes I
recently read A Brief History of Time Of
course by the great Stephen Hawking this
is a book that I have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
davidpackman I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the David packman show at
davidpackman.com all right let's hear
from some people via the David packman
show Discord you can find it at
davidpackman.com Discord approaching we
are getting dangerously close to 12
000 Discord subscribers which is just
insane inconceivable let's go first to
uh Josh from Mexico City Josh I would
love to hear what's going on there
hi David can you hear me I I can I I
can't help but ask where you are exactly
because it's such a compelling
background noise uh the park you're at
the park all right park in Mexico City
I've got a picture in my head what's
going on there yeah so I had a question
for you it seems like the the Biden
Administration one of their big things
was was racial Justice
and um and since the United Nations uh
committee on uh I believe it's
unrecognized or uh decolonization has
specifically called out the U.S in terms
of its relationship with with the
territories and overseas possessions
um does it seem likely that it also
given that Puerto Rico uh has more or
less
uh definitively voted on on statehood if
you call it that um does it seem likely
that that the Biden Administration will
make a an attempt to uh sort of
normalize the status of the of the
territories especially American Samoa
where they're not where they don't even
have the right to Birthright citizenship
you know it doesn't strike me that this
is going to be at the top of the list of
priorities for Democrats and for Joe
Biden's Administration in these first
two years to me and this is not my
opinion of what should happen I think it
should be a priority it seems to me that
it's more likely to be a sort of 2022 to
2024 priority and then of course you
need to wait and see if Democrats will
even have the house and or Senate that's
my sense right now I'm not seeing like a
big political appetite for it and
particularly when you know stimulus was
going to be done right away it took
months I I I'm not super optimistic it
gets done in these first two years sure
sure but thanks thanks David what are
you doing in Mexico City do you live
there yes I I'm half Chicano oh okay so
I uh I was here working on my PhD before
before lockdown and uh
so now I live here how are things from
the standpoint of the virus
it's complicated yeah um the the
government has
started to roll out the the Russian
vaccine yep um but of course you have
this is this is of course a country
where that's that's complicated you know
you could say it's only been a democracy
for the past 20 years
and uh you know you have people you have
you have the the informal and formal
economy right people who work in the
formal economy are are are doing okay
it's the people who work in the informal
economy that have received no no
protection are there ways if you are an
elite so to speak to get the Pfizer or
moderna vaccines there
uh what I've what I've what I've heard
from some friends
um is that people are going to their uh
summer houses in in Florida to get it
right or things of that nature that that
seems to be the best way yep to do it
I've read that about Argentina as well
people people who were going to Miami
yeah yeah yeah it's that's pretty much
that's pretty much what's what's
happening and what's what's also
interesting is that when they did the
initial contact tracing they traced the
first case of actually the first cluster
of cases
in Mexico City to uh a group of uh
Elites who who went to Aspen oh really
the quarantine yes so not shocking not
shocking all right Josh thank you
appreciate the call yeah thank you David
all right there's a Josh from Mexico
City let's go next to Sarah from
Washington DC Sarah you're on the air
hey
Hi how are you
good how are you doing well
you've actually never talked to you
before
um I watch everything you do
um
yeah
um I'm just honestly here to listen and
like learn oh you didn't want to ask a
question
I mean you know I'm just listening and
here I like what you do so I'm just here
to listen and take in what I can I
didn't really have a specific question
all right well thank you I appreciate it
of course all right there we go Sarah
from Washington DC let's next go to Nico
from Santa Monica Nico you're on the air
hi David how are you
I'm good thank you
um
so I assume you follow either the New
York or the New York Times or Bloomberg
vaccine tracker correct yes I do
I was wondering so that the Johnson
Johnson vaccine has been approved
um for for use and
that data is not showing up yet are
people just not getting the vaccine
or so as of earlier this week the new so
after the jnj was approved but before
this week when you looked at I haven't
looked at the Bloomberg tracker for a
while but when you would look at the New
York Times it would say jnj has been
approved we have no data on it it's not
included in our tracker as of this week
There's a new message on the New York
Times tracker which says jnj one dose is
now included here and we are including
now because it's one dose if you got the
jnj vaccine you're being counted by the
New York Times both as having
full vaccination and as having at least
one dose they're basically double it's
not really double counting you're just
you're part of both categories so my
understanding is now jnj is in the New
York Times tracker
okay so so that vaccine data is updated
then yes as far as I know
all right well thank you all right Nico
from Santa Monica with a very
um
specific question I guess is what we
would say
why don't we go next to amugo from
Florida a mugo you were on the air hey
dude can you hear me yes I can
all right how you doing I'm doing well
uh so I kind of have a few questions
we'll start I'm going to start off with
this one right did you hear about the
Nevada Democratic party how basically
the establishment just quit after the
Socialist one wand facing all the seats
I saw a headline about it I don't know
the details about what's been going on
in in the Nevada Democratic party but I
did see the headline yeah
yeah I just thought it was interesting
you know
the social experience took over and you
know the the establishments talks about
unity and blah blah blah and then as
soon as you know the people that they
weren't really expecting to win Juan
they kind of just quit and it was just
one of those like hypocritical type
things like you want to work together
but when you don't get your way you just
just go away that's
I didn't like I just it was just funny
to me yeah it is it is funny based on
the headlines I've seen I plan to do a
deeper dive on it this weekend when I
have some time to to read more stuff
about it but I'm curious as to like the
the background on it I don't know
whether this is something that's been
building within the Democratic party
there for some time or or if this like
punctually exploded or what happened but
it's it sounds very odd and
counterproductive to be quite Frank yeah
question was
um on this stimulus package you know you
I feel like what Democrats could do in
the 2022 midterms emphasize hey you know
we're trying to pass this bill and the
majority of the GOP like Republican
voters are on our side yes but yet no
Republicans supported it so couldn't
they use that as like a messaging tool
for 2022. I hope so I've been talking
about this for a while which is if every
Republican wants to vote against
something that many Republican voters
actually want there you would hope that
there are political ramifications to
that and you would imagine that
Democrats would figure out a way to try
to hold them to account for that in 2022
by running on they voted no on you
getting any money unfortunately
political memories are very short and if
we're significantly recovered by 2022
and Republicans have fully switched over
to the debt the deficit cancel culture
all this stuff
it may just be too late people may have
forgotten about it sadly I hate that
that's a reality yeah because I was
thinking about it because there's a new
poll that just came out
um a Hugo poll I believe in Australia 75
of Americans want this bill at 59 of
Republicans want it but yet no
Republicans voted for it so yeah they're
not representing their constituents by
by definition literally they're in a
mathematical sense they are not doing it
and for all the flaws Democrats have I
mean at least they're trying to get past
because there's a lot of flaws with the
bill you know the 15 minimum wage yeah
more means testing so there's a lot of
things that aren't good about it at
least they're trying to get relief done
but the rights talking about Dr Seuss so
this was my exact commentary which is
there's a bunch of issues where
Democrats and Republicans aren't very
different but you look at this every
Republican voted for people to get
nothing Democrats frustratingly they
don't want the 15 minimum wage and
remember it's not like there's there's
Democratic senators who would have voted
no even if you push it into the bill
that's the that's the frustration they
added they restricted who gets it but
but they pass something if it were up to
Republicans people would get zero
and then my final point is um Tom Cotton
I think
um I don't know if you mentioned it I
don't know who it was but Tom Cotton
went on Fox News and said oh the
Democrats want to give uh prisoners like
I can't remember who the church guy was
I can't remember but they want to give
him a 14 check owes The Young Turks and
um that same provision was in the Trump
stimulus bill but now Tom Cotton hates
it now Democrats trying to do the exact
same thing like wasn't it like the
Boston Bomber they were talking about
yeah the Boston box
I mean this is the same thing as when
they say there's a projection of a
hundred thousand children coming across
the border that will that those are
almost identical numbers to what there
was under Trump it's just Fox News
wasn't talking about it then
yeah it it's honestly frustrating just
like listening to them it's like listen
Democrats have the flaws but at least
they're trying to help you guys are just
complain and complain did you see um Tim
Ryan on the house floor basically
yelling at Republicans like I did we're
trying to help the workers like what are
you guys do you complain and complain so
Tim Ryan's a good guy we've had him on
the show and I've met him a couple times
really really good guy
at that moment I was like
it's not like you know he's he's not
inspiring as a progressive leader but
he's he's relatively Progressive and uh
a good a good guy all right amugo thank
you for the call
it's no problem have a good day all
right there is a mugo from Florida or
Florida I should have asked which of the
two he's from actually let's go next to
uh why don't we go to
kibo from Brussels Belgium Tebow you're
on the air
hi David can you hear me I can hear you
perfectly
so first I wanted to ask
um how are people coping in America with
like the stimulus checks because I am
raised by a single mother and she
um has a beauty salon and in Belgium all
the contact jobs or close contact jobs
had to close for several months gone
every month she got an amount of money
proportionate to her income
and I just can't imagine
um how Americans can live without
paychecks for so many months it's uh
it's it there's a there's a range I mean
you know fortunately lots of people had
jobs that translated to work from home
but many people did not of course
um a lot of people are on unemployment
and struggling on unemployment in fact
we did a story earlier this week on the
bonus show
that's the award-winning bonus show
Tebow by the way uh we did a story on
the bonus show about how one-third of
those receiving unemployment in February
were struggling to pay for food and
housing so the even people on
unemployment are struggling right now a
lot of younger people have moved back in
with parents I mean there's not one it's
a very good question there's not one
answer but different people are coping
in different ways into different degrees
but it's it's pathetic what what hasn't
been done here compared to what Europe
has done
yeah and like um is it also uh in
America that also certain jobs had to
just close for several months or is it
just a state-by-state legislated well
the answer is yes but it was based on a
state-by-state basis so there were long
periods where in certain States things
like you know massage therapy was just
closed um hair salons closed things like
this it is decided upon at the state
level so there's kind of like a
different answers in different states
but yeah that was that was the case
okay I understand yeah and I just wanted
to ask you also about
um Bernie Sanders sure
um like he is uh I believe uh the
chairman of the Senate budget committee
right
um like what is what are his powers or
what can he basically get done for you
guys it's not clear I mean listen the
powers are enumerated you could just
Google exactly what the powers are and
it has to do with agenda setting in that
in that committee
um what he can do unilaterally is is
very much unclear and he's still going
to need to build consensus with the
broader Democratic party I think but
it's still a good thing to have him in
that role but if people are expecting
Bernie to unilaterally get a ton done
because he's in that position I think
that that expectation probably will
leave you disappointed
and did the establishments um give him
that position or did he get voted to
that chair position he was voted to he
he was selected by the senate for that
yeah I mean isn't that like
pretty great for progressives absolutely
I mean the question will be things are
abnormal right now because of the
pandemic once things normalize then we
will get to see okay from the
progressive agenda what will be done and
what can Bernie help push along in his
role as Senate budget chairman we just
don't know yet
mm-hmm because like in the house like
the progressive candidates like AOC yeah
um they just didn't get like hype any
High positions right that is essentially
correct and um we will see if that
changes in 2022.
yeah okay thanks there's among
Christians thank you so how are things
okay in Brussels otherwise it's one of
my favorite cities
uh yeah we just had like uh some really
bad news we had an incident
um not yesterday but the day before with
gay bashing
um so some young people
um went on a gay meeting app and they uh
made contact with an old man they just
um
uh waited on him like in a park or
something and that man was killed oh my
good sexuality so we're currently facing
that and like the whole country is now
yeah a little bit shocked that's that's
horrifying to end on a high note can you
still get the really great fries in
Brussels with the different sauces or is
that shut down because of the pandemic
uh we have the best price in the world
right no I don't disagree
uh our the french fries were originally
from Belgium so you can't say they are
really french fries but
um we made the best present yeah we
still have them but a lot of Chinese
people
um come uh come to Belgium to like open
uh how do you say it
um like if a french fry business okay a
fry shot yes yeah we have so many but
they make really good french fries but
yeah it's really funny
what's your favorite sauce the curry
ketchup or what
oh no I we have this one sauce called
yopi sauce okay it's like this yellow
sauce I don't know where it's coming
from but uh if you ever come to Belgium
it could be anything it could be
anything yeah no no I've been to Belgium
I tried a bunch of the sauces I did not
I did not try that one but uh yellow I
will go for any day you know yeah yeah
all right Tebow from Brussels I
appreciate it thank you
bye all right wow wow what a call all
right let's take a quick break if you're
holding to talk to me please don't hang
up because I'm going right back to the
phones in just a moment the David Pacman
show at davidpackman.com
foreign
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
David packman show has been and
continues to be membership and
membership is not just a feel-good thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show every single day just for members
as well as commercial free audio and
video feeds of the show day in and day
out you can sign up for membership very
very quickly at joinpakman.com that's
join
p-a-k-m-a-n.com if the normal prices
strike you is high by all means use the
coupon code better 21 all one word all
lower case become a member today
foreign
[Music]
let's go next to Lucian from England
you're on the air
hello David how are you
I'm good how are you I'm doing well
all right so um so I saw that a few days
ago you responded to a caller who was
asking about the idea of having
conversations with other public speakers
like yourself but on the right yes
um I sorry if we spoke about it again
since but I haven't quite caught up on
the vids okay
um you seemed fairly open to the idea at
the end of that and I think you asked
the audience if they'd be interested
right
um so my thoughts I've had thoughts on
this for for a while wanted to speak to
about it because I think I'm quite
worried that people can become quite
insular and sort of stick to their own
kind so to say and taking everything
these people say as gospel and I wonder
to what extent you think this has
contributed to polarization we see today
you're saying that maybe not enough
conversations between left and right are
happening and that leads to more
polarization
yes and you you did say and I understand
that you said it's quite hard to make it
a productive thing yeah maybe especially
if you're trying to speak to the likes
of Tucker but um would you be sort of
willing to try it and maybe lead maybe
sort of like lead by example to get the
public to be more open to by partnership
yeah I mean listen here's the thing the
call that I got last week from people
saying why not do more of the you know
kind of like blood sport type debates
with kooky right Wingers that's very
different than when like for example I
had on Neil Ferguson who's someone from
the right who we can engage in a more
meaningful way to hopefully try to
understand each other or like when I
head on
um who else there's a there's a bunch of
different people I've had on where it's
it's sort of more uh normal in a sense I
think that that's great and I have been
doing that and continue to do that I
think that the question from the from
the caller was more like more cartoonish
debates with Tim Poole or like the
Westboro Baptist Church lunatics or
stuff like that where that I don't see
as as productive
um but you know like when I have Neil
Ferguson on or people like that I think
that that that is that is good and I
plan to continue doing that
yes I I really hope it's making a
difference I just think both sides
really love to demonize each other so
much yeah I think if if the people we
look up to for this kind of information
if we see them sit down and talk
constructively right when it won't fix
the problem but I think it could go a
long way I don't disagree I I I'm
completely on board and yeah my
interpretation of last week's question
was more about like the wacky right
Wingers where it's just like you know
how much do we really look it's like
funny to do Jesse Lee Peterson interview
but it's kind of a waste of time too
of course yeah
thank you very much all right thank you
so much yeah very very good point glad
to have the opportunity to clarify and
explore further
why don't we speak next to
uh oh I don't know I mean there's so
many different people
interested in getting on
why don't we go to Trey from Seattle
Trey from Seattle you're on there
hello can you hear me yes I can
hey David I was just wondering what do
you think the future of the Republican
party is
too soon to know too soon to know I
think that you know uh so what we see
right now is a power struggle Donald
Trump at his CPAC speech saying here's a
list of Republicans that are bad
and that I'm going to try to defeat and
you can donate to me I will be the king
maker in 2022. on the other hand you
have some Republicans who remain behind
Donald Trump others who want the
Republican party to get out from Trump
you have a legal battle right now where
the Republican party is saying we can
use Trump's name and likeness to
fundraise whereas Trump is saying stop
using my name people should donate to me
and I'll decide who is going to win in
the Republican party we just have to
wait and see in 2022 who wins and who
loses do Marjorie Taylor green and
Lauren bobert and Madison cawthorne get
reelected or do they get humiliated and
made one term trumpian uh radicals I
just think we don't know yet what the
future of the party is
interesting yeah I I've done a lot of
research on to kind of the
evolution of the Republican party and I
found it that
it's almost as if each generation has
tried to out conservative
the other
um but not Trump I mean trumps think oh
until Trump yeah right because because
Trump ran on a whole different Paradigm
which was just kind of shock value and
faux populism right yeah it went from
you know Richard Nixon EPA like you said
I believe a 1.2
you know queuing on crazies like
Marjorie Taylor green right but in the
middle of that in the middle there's no
there's important stuff in the middle
which was Reaganomics and then the
radicalization of Newt Gingrich and then
the sort of dim-witted George W bush and
then the racism inspired by Obama and
that all culminated in Trump
right yeah and uh my last question for
you is uh about the green New Deal sure
uh what do you think we could do to
modify it or make it less radical which
parts are radical
what's up which parts are radical
well forgive me I haven't read the
entire bill so is there any of it that
you can point to that's radical
uh 100
relying 100 on renewable energy by what
date
uh what I'm sorry well that's only
radical if we say that it's going to be
by three years from now right like
eventually it wouldn't be radical to say
at some point we should get to that it
becomes a question of when is it
reasonable right yeah
um I hoped I hope that the bill is
meaning that this is going to be a more
smooth transition towards that and I
want that to happen yeah and not so
abruptly
um it can't happen abruptly because we
don't have the supply you know anybody
who's scared that abruptly we're gonna
have to be only be depending on wind we
we don't have the supply by definition
it will have to be a you know a a
relatively long transition right right
well thank you very much David no
problem yeah but so find the parts that
you find to be radical and then let's
talk again
oh yes yes all right trade from Seattle
very good yeah I mean if you if you're
gonna say it's um
if you're going to say it's radical
you've got to tell me what is radical
and uh yeah all right good let's go next
to why don't we go to
um
let's go to Javi from
from where where is Hobby from North
Carolina Javi from North Carolina you're
on there
hey David can you hear me yes I can
okay awesome so
um I basically am pretty worried and
terrified that 2022 and 24 are going to
be a bloodbath for the Democrats okay I
just kind of wanted to lay out my case
why and I get your thoughts on it sure
so
you know I I just the I think to start
with the fact that we were unable to
easily and clearly defeat
um an incompetent [ __ ] like Trump in
2020 and the fact that it was as close
as it was that the Republicans picked up
seats in itself I thought was a pretty
bad sign yep
um I feel like the
um I feel like the right has done a good
job
especially over the last year and I feel
like they may be effective in doing this
going forward at tying the left like the
Democrats to
um a lot of cultural issues that are BS
that that can be appealing to appealing
to sort of nonpartisans or apolitical
people so like tying the Democrats to
cancel culture or
um
you know just political correctness and
identity politics and all that stuff and
there I feel like their party has that
like they're shifting into a more
establishment uh it's a more
anti-establishment party at least the
Aesthetics are even if they're not on
the policy but I feel like policy is is
really starting to matter less and less
these days yeah and
um and also I just feel like the fact
that on the left I feel like we are
really having a Civil War and the right
is not I feel like the right-wing base
it's pretty United behind Trump it's
only like the DC
um politicians of the media people that
are having the Civil War but even on the
left our civil war isn't just
establishment left versus populist left
like even in the populist left we have
with like you know Jimmy Dore and Glenn
Greenwald and everyone fighting against
other like you know progressives on the
left and stuff like that and I just feel
like all this is creating The Perfect
Storm to work okay so yeah yeah that's
that's a ton of stuff so I'll just
mention a few things one is that I think
the I'll go kind of go backwards the
infighting on the left it's not clear to
me that it's really having electoral
repercussions at this point in time
because in the end you've got a lot of
people who are very loud but they don't
vote regardless like they're not voting
either way so it kind of doesn't matter
whether they are in disagreement with
what's going on in the Democratic party
because either way they just they're
they're tweeting but they're not
actually voting that's part of it
another part of it is that
um I I think that we you are right in
being sort of concerned about how
difficult it was to defeat Trump in the
end and barely won the Senate did
Democrats and lost some seats in the
house but I think that there's a unique
situation 2024 I'm not even going to
think about until after we get 2022. for
2022 if it simply ends up being a
referendum on
did Joe Biden get the economy back to
sort of where it was before the pandemic
did Joe Biden deal with vaccination well
did Joe Biden get stimulus done did Joe
Biden get some other legislative
accomplishment you may see a reversal of
the normal Trend which is one party wins
the White House and then two years later
loses the house and or Senate you may
actually see Democrats do really well in
November of 2022. I think it's too soon
to know and and I think we we have to
wait and see but I think it's completely
plausible Democrats do fine in 2022.
okay yeah well you know I just think
Biden won't get enough done to energize
or to satisfy the progressive left and
and keep them energized to come out in
2022 and then the I guess sort of the
last point that I missed was I just feel
like 2022 alone is going to be a blood
blast because of the gerrymandering
that's going to come after the the
census as the Republicans control the
state legislators they're going to
redraw the districts to favor them and
uh and that's a real issue that's a real
issue and the and the electoral map for
2024 even there's more votes that are
shifting towards Texas and Florida you
know state for leaning more Republicans
so that those are just that's just why
I'm pretty concerned about that all
right well we're going to follow it all
but I uh I think your concerns are
reasonable and and we will have plenty
of time to discuss for sure I appreciate
the call
thank you David all right thanks
everybody who called I unfortunately
need to uh hang it up there but we will
take calls again and I hope to hear from
you next time
the David packman show at
davidpackman.com
[Music]
the David packman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month plus you can get
the daily bonus show world famous at
this point and the daily commercial free
TV show by making those pledges at
patreon.com
davidpackman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners whether you
listen to the podcast watch on YouTube
or watch us on TV or even listen on the
radio patreon.com
davidpackman show
the David packman show at
davidpackman.com
all right let's get into audience
questions for the week first one is
about the 1.9 trillion dollar
coronavirus stimulus Bill uh Dave and
there's a bunch of versions of this
going around
uh but the question is why are all of
these right Wingers saying that most of
the 1.9 trillion has nothing to do with
coronavirus if it's a coronavirus relief
bill now this isn't true we're going to
go through what is in this bill and
actually uh talk about the origins of
this claim that most of the money isn't
for covid stimulus but this is not a new
claim from Republicans they did the
exact same thing with Hurricane Sandy
Hurricane Sandy when it hit New York and
New Jersey years ago I think it was
2012. the response Bill contained not
only money to fix the damage that
happened but also because American uh
infrastructure is woefully outdated and
because we haven't elected a a system of
elected government that doesn't
incentivize thinking proactively
spending now to prevent a problem in the
future that will cause us to spend more
money we are in the unfortunate
situation where sometimes in order to
get things fixed and prevent future
problems you have to do it when a system
breaks and you have a a problem
with Hurricane Sandy you saw that there
was a bunch of money in the Hurricane
Sandy relief bill which people like Ted
Cruz referred to as pork and there was
some pork but a lot of it was was not
that meant to strengthen infrastructure
when you look at the flooding that took
place when you look at the breakdown of
all sorts of different resources and
infrastructure at that time the idea was
hey we now have evidence that because we
didn't strengthen this stuff because
it's so not robust it's so fragile
when we have a situation like a
hurricane that hits an area that less
frequently gets hurricanes New York and
New Jersey all this stuff breaks so as
part of recovering let's also strengthen
things for the future okay with that
framework the meme that's been going
around is well hold on a second if each
American not everybody but most
Americans get 1400 bucks and then you
get some money for kids you'll see it
floating around that only a few hundred
billion of the 1.9 trillion is for covid
this is so silly but because it's being
repeated so much it's worth
understanding that in the 1.9 trillion
you have for example 160 billion for
vaccine purchases distribution injection
as well as covid testing that's covid
related it's not cash for people but the
more we vaccinate the the faster we do
away with this pandemic and the more the
economy will recover
come on guys you're saying that's not
actually for covid 360 billion for state
and local governments to make sure that
they are solvent solvent many states
because of the when you have a reduction
in business activity states where those
businesses exist take in reduced tax
revenue the states still hopefully are
providing police fire school you know
all this different stuff so as a result
of coronavirus a bunch of different
states need money you're really going to
say that's not coronavirus related
um eight and a half billion for Rural
hospitals to stay open and of course
those are going to be important
vaccination sites in rural areas 25
billion to fund Child Care Centers it
that you're going to say that has
nothing to do with coronavirus one of
the issues we have right now is many
parents can't get back to work
if their kids aren't back in school so
you very quickly start to understand why
funding child care which by the way we
don't fund enough in this country anyway
is related to coronavirus 15 billion to
subsidize child care for essential
workers we need our essential workers to
be working they need to be working to
make money
but if they have to be taking care of
their kids they can't work and then they
can't put food on their family's table
this is its coronavirus related why are
we in this situation 130 billion for
K-12 schools to reopen and decrease
class sizes it costs money to decrease
class sizes to open safely if you
decrease class sizes you either need
additional teachers to have way more
classes or you need to be paying
overtime if teachers are going to be
doing two sessions however you're going
to do it it's going to cost money
people on the right want schools open
people on the left want schools open
safely here's money in order to do that
we could go on and on and on you know um
15 billion dollars to prevent Airline
layoffs okay there are some who are
saying Airlines should be allowed to
fail unfortunately
fortunately or unfortunately whatever
the case may be airlines are a big piece
of infrastructure Transportation
infrastructure you could make the case
let them fail but we're going to be
depending on airlines if and when things
start to improve uh to allow Commerce
and allow travel to restart travel one
of the hardest hit Industries so you
know you you can make a case on any of
these things well maybe the 15 should be
12 or something like that but the the
talking point that's floating around is
most of the money has nothing to do with
coronavirus and of course that is
completely and totally untrue this isn't
a new talking point from the right and
it's not at all surprising that they're
rehashing it and Reviving it right now
hey David how much longer do you think
we're going to need coronavirus stimulus
bills so there's two questions here how
much longer will we need them and is
there really a shot at getting another
one I've said before this third
coronavirus stimulus
I think in all likelihood is going to be
the last now I know that there are lots
of folks who have put out very good
proposals sort of pandemic basic income
versions of universal basic income
continue doing uh 2 000 bucks a month or
a thousand bucks a month or whatever the
case may be until certain economic
metrics have been met others are into
that idea but only on a means tested
basis I think it's all going to be moot
I believe that the political appetite
for Corona these big coronavirus
stimulus packages Maybe I'm Wrong I
think this is the last one I don't think
there's going to be a fourth one but
that wasn't really the question the
question was how how much longer do you
think the the economy in Americans will
need stimulus
I think the the reality is that soon
um the case for acute coveted stimulus
as an umbrella
if we continue vaccinating
if the variants don't completely upend
what we're trying to do and the
reductions that we're seeing my hope is
that we will have a dramatically
recovered economy
um probably by the beginning of the
fourth quarter of this year although
some Industries are going to need help
for longer what I think is missing in
this question how much longer will we
need covid stimulus is that what we
really need and this has been exposed by
the pandemic we need the systemic
changes that many social Democrats like
me have been advocating for for over a
decade at this point in time and as we
pointed out when the virus first hit
systems we think are robust are actually
really fragile remember what happened
with food supply and toilet paper just
an example of systems we think very
little about day to day
but as soon as you have a shock to the
system it becomes extraordinarily
fragile some of these examples of
fragility include significant income
inequality when a pandemic hits income
inequality in this case became
dramatically exacerbated so when you
start with an unequal situation you have
a massive collapse of the economy and
then you get a k-shaped recovery where
the very rich do really really well and
a lot of people do not that is an
example of something where a more robust
system of social safety nets among many
other changes and policies we've been
talking about health care not being
linked to employment and so many other
things living wage all these different
things they make the system less fragile
to begin with and so I think that
there's a debate to be had as to should
there be a fourth coronavirus stimulus
would there be an appetite for something
else in May or in June or whatever the
case may be maybe they can get it done
maybe they can't
much less coveted stimulus would have
been needed obviously if Trump had
better handled the virus and not as many
jobs had been lost and all of that but
just as importantly
if the systemic changes I've been
talking about for a decade were in place
things wouldn't have gotten nearly as
bad as they got if people at Health Care
are not connected to work if social
safety nets were more robust if
everybody earned a living wage right we
we really need change for everyone
systemically rather than I would argue
another bill that helps some people even
if it's most if the current recovery
continues job creation
reduction in unemployment rate
reductions in deaths reductions in
hospitalizations we're seeing a lot of
jobs come back as part-time which
hopefully will become full-time we
talked about the jobs report uh from
February at the beginning of the week
and
um it's you know this this third
stimulus makes sense economically and
politically Joe Biden ran on it promised
it many Senate Democrat Democratic
candidates also ran on it
um it would be a major failure not to
have done it we're not at a point where
we can say we don't need that my hope is
that in three to four months we'll be at
a point
where we'll be able to say we need very
targeted stimulus for people in
particular situations but now it's time
to fix the systems and do the real
infrastructure spending so that the next
pandemic isn't as big as a disaster at
this one right now it's too early virus
is still causing a lot of damage a lot
of people are still unemployed will be
unemployed for the foreseeable future
where nine million jobs short of where
we were before the pandemic so you give
people checks you provide a buffer you
enhance unemployment child tax credits
all these things eventually if anything
good comes from this virus in the United
States it would be realizing how far
behind we are so many other rich
countries when it comes to social safety
nets and dampening the blow of something
like this to begin with I'm probably
being naively optimistic given some of
the people that are representing Us in
the House and Senate right now and that
actually relates to the next question
we're going to talk about David do you
think that the lunatic trumpist elected
officials that won in 2020 like Marjorie
Taylor green Lauren bobert Madison
cawthorne and others will be re-elected
in 2022. this is a cut this is like a
chicken egg question we wonder Will
trump really run in 2024 we wonder is
the Republican party going in the
direction of trump or are they going to
reject Trump going forward
that and this question of do Marjorie
Taylor green Madison cawthorne and
Lauren bobert become one-term anomalies
or anomalies depending on your
preference both pronunciation is valid
or do they get re-elected and ingrain
these sort of vapid trumpian candidates
with no policy ideas
um into Congress the Tea Party in 2010
you'll remember
essentially disappeared as a standalone
group it's now a caucus within the House
of Representatives and many tea party
ideas sort of became integrated into the
Republican party but not as cartoonishly
as they presented themselves in 2010.
something similar could happen with
trumpism were some of these folks
moderate and remain in the party or they
all get crushed in 2022 and that signals
a broader rejection of trumpism going
forward I think the reason that at his
speech at CPAC a week or two ago
two weeks ago wait three two weeks it
you know recently uh I don't even know I
don't even know what year it is never
mind when Trump spoke no in the last
month Trump spoke at CPAC one of the
reasons strategically that it made sense
for Trump not to announce a 2024 run but
to announce that he now is going to be
helping candidates in 2022 to donate to
his pack so on and so forth is that
gauging his level of influence through
the elections of those he supports in
2022 will serve as a good signal as to
whether he should run in 2024 whether he
has a shot in 2024 so I think the answer
is it remains to be seen
Trump's influence will determine whether
cawthorne bobert and green get reelected
green cawthorne and bobert getting
reelected or not will signal the
strength of trumpism going into 2024
which will likely inform whether or not
Donald Trump runs I still lean to Trump
doesn't run
my my thought is that to some degree
trumpism will fade over the next two to
three years Trump will be nearly 80. and
I see him just kind of moving on to
something else or for other reasons uh
you know a health becomes more of a
question mark and uh Trump is not a
particularly healthy guy My overall
prediction is if I had to bet today I
bet if you give me even odds and I'm not
a betting man but if you gave me even
odds I bet Trump doesn't run in 2024.
let me know your thoughts we've got a
great bonus show for you today get
instant access to the bonus show by
signing up right now at joinpakman.com
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com davidpackman